it's one of the most difficult legal
issues of our times how to protect both
newly established gay rights and our
long-standing religious liberties when
they come into conflict the Oregon Court
of Appeals ruled yesterday against a
couple who were fined 135 thousand
dollars after their bakery declined to
make a wedding cake for lesbian partners
the attorney for the four bakers Melissa
and Aaron Klein said his clients were
deprived at the Constitution's promises
of religious liberty and free speech how
do we find that balance in these thorny
issues when everybody's rights want to
be respected joining us now for this
discussion from Austin Texas is Robert
heniki the general counsel and director
for the Center for the American future
along with Robin biro an LGBTQ activist
in an Army Ranger veteran who is in
Atlanta first Robin I want to thank you
for your your service to our country and
protecting the protecting United States
and your service in our military really
do it early do appreciate that but I
want to start with Robert here why is
this a religious liberty First Amendment
issue as opposed to what what Robbins
gonna argue which is something a bit
different than that why why does look
religious liberty and the First
Amendment Trump what is going on here
Jason thank you for having me on the
program the central issue in this case
is whether the judiciary should decide
what constitutes artistic expression
legally it's uncharted territory for
courts to say what is art and what is
not and here the oregon appellate court
got it wrong when they decided that the
artistry expressed by mrs. Kline in her
custom handcrafted cakes was not
entitled to the same type of First
Amendment protection that's afforded to
other mediums of artistry and artistic
expression now they did have an Oregon
State law that they were looking to
write but the issue that they're gonna
be arguing and wanting to appeal is
going to be based on the First Amendment
issue correct well the way they got
around that was in going into the public
doctrine that looks at ordinary
businesses engaged in commerce
as brick-and-mortar type operations that
fall outside of typical First Amendment
freedom of expression and religious
freedom protections but the Court did
that to get to the end result that it
wanted to accomplish and in doing so and
ignore the fact that mrs. Klein's
business was not just an ordinary bakery
it was a service and artistic expression
that she did using her hands in creating
these type of cakes which was the way
that she expressed herself and the
Constitution is clear that the First
Amendment protects that type of artistic
expression which unfortunately the
Oregon Court failed to recognize and got
wrong here
now Robin as you look at this case how
do you how do you see it because my
guess is you have got a little different
take on this I do and thank you for
having me on I appreciate the
opportunity I want to make one point
clear the reason that the fine was a
hundred and thirty-five thousand dollars
was because these bakers doxxed the
individuals who were declined service
they put their personal information out
attacked their children turn them into
CPS and verb they were vilified them
this has nothing to do with artistic
expression they flat-out denied them
service that's discrimination that is
not an American value and I frankly I
would like to point out that I really
see this as an identity politic
on the on the side of the right LGBT
Americans just want to be treated like
everybody else the Golden Rule I don't I
do not want to be turned away and
discriminated against this is not about
cakes this is just wanting to be treated
the same as everyone else we would
frankly like to stop this identity
politic
of being singled out I happen to be a
gay Army Ranger my arranger buddies
never treated me any different than any
of my peers as long as I shot fine and
I'll held my Ranger standards nobody
cared now do you believe Robert though
that I Robin I should say do you believe
there's any room for religious liberty
if this really truly is a long-standing
true belief in their religious liberty
why can't they make this decision there
that's a great question I'm glad you
posed it there's a case in Colorado
where a customer wanted to make a cake
in the shape of a Bible that's
homosexuality is a sin and in that case
that was a First Amendment issue but the
Baker sold them the cake sold them the
bag of icing and said they could write
whatever they wanted to on it so in that
case it didn't violate any laws they
didn't discriminate against against the
person's religious liberties so that's
where the line is this is about
discrimination though these people were
flat-out told that they were not going
to be served because they were gay and I
understand the argument that why give a
homophobic Baker your money but the
issue is it comes down to discrimination
and that's just not like I said it's not
an American and value it's not okay
we're all just Americans please let's
move past identity politics no one cares
that I'm gay and this religious Baker
has no right to force her religious
beliefs on me
we're business Robert where is the line
with religious liberty and this case is
ultimately going to be decided by the
Supreme Court cuz there is a different
case that is pending before the court
correct well that's right and this organ
case the Clym case will you know end up
being a footnote of little consequence
given that the United States Supreme
Court is currently considering the
masterpiece cake shop case and in the
recent oral arguments before the US
Supreme Court the justices specifically
Justice Kennedy and Justice Roberts
we're talking about where this tension
exists in the tuggin war between the two
sides and and how they're grappling with
that issue
unfortunately the Oregon appellate court
avoided that issue and instead a
shoehorned mrs. Klein's artistry into
just rather the public doctrine and for
in terms of a brick and mortar business
the real discrimination here is in not
recognizing that the masterpieces that
she created with her hands were her form
of expression and that she's entitled to
First Amendment protection for that
artistry especially in so far is that
it's an expression of her also genuine
deeply held religious beliefs Robin I'll
give you the last word quickly we've got
just a few seconds last word like I said
just please treat us the same as anyone
else lived by the golden rule
be head tree us the way that you
yourself want to be treated pls
discrimination is never okay and that's
what I see this as gentlemen thank you
both Happy New Year